is it better to make a number of
adequate weapons that are easy to
operate and maintain
or should you start with a premise that
if it's not
perfect it's not good one theme that
resonates in all discussions of world
war
ii and has come up in both air and naval
power
is this idea of gigantism or the age-old
debate
on whether quality or quantity is more
important
and nowhere is this clear when we get to
questions of tanks and artillery
in other words is it better to make a
number of adequate
weapons that are easy to operate and
maintain
or should you start with a premise that
if it's
not perfect it's not good in other words
we want a few
quality weapons even if they're somewhat
on pr
impractical or they're hard to maintain
or they're expensive to produce at least
on paper they're superior to what the
enemy has
in the terms of tanks had the germans
not built
1600 tigers or 600 king
tigers or not have wasted so much money
on this mouse program a crazy idea of
building a 200 ton
super tank then they might have built
another 5 000
mark iv tanks that with their latest
improvement
and updating were almost comparable to
the t34 at the end of the war
same is true with the v1 and v2 programs
as we saw if they hadn't
of invested in the v2 rocket program and
used those resources to either build
four engine bombers or more v1 cruise
missiles
they would have been far better off
against the enemy they would have
inflicted far more damage but there's
some kind of innate
human desire to make something big and
perfect even if it's not
practical in terms of artillery pieces
this same dichotomy warred within german
planning
discussions they came up with this 88
millimeter
flat gun that turned out when it was the
trajectory was lowered it turned out to
be the best anti-tank gun it was very
easy to use it was very accurate it was
very easy to transport it was very easy
to make
and it was absolutely lethal to every
allied tank that came and came in
contact with it but the problem was
as we said earlier if they're needed to
protect german cities
from allied bombers then they're not
blowing up soviet tanks so the question
is
why not build more of them and one of
the answers why you didn't build more of
them was
hitler had this fixation with gigantism
and this manifested itself out with
things like gustav not 88 millimeters
not 100 millimeters not
200 millimeters not 400 millimeters not
700 millimeters
800 millimeters largest gun made in
world war ii
7 500 germans soldiers were needed just
to
transport it to the eastern front
reassemble it
and then maybe you could shoot one
projectile
per minute but not more than 200
or 300 when the barrel started to wear
out and although the projectile would
weigh three or four thousand pounds
depending
on the uh explosive that was
that was uh desired when it was fired at
say sebastopol
it wasn't the reason that the germans
took sevastopol they were much better
with
smaller caliber faster firing easily
maintained
uh cannon but in addition to gustav they
had a number of huge mortars
400 millimeter mortars 200 millimeter
mortars
and the german industrial
sector taking orders from hitler spent
an
inordinate amount of its resources on
building
fantastic weapons big weapons
huge weapons when it should have made
much smaller ones
this was a directly opposite of the
russian
and the american idea especially
especially when we come to artillery
the soviet union made more artillery
pieces over 300
000 than almost any other country and
they killed about
75 percent of german soldiers who were
killed on the eastern front and
they even went a step beyond artillery
with the katushka rocket they thought
you know what
making artillery barrel and rifling the
inside and
requires a lot of expense and
craftsmanship and some
knowledge or expertise to aim and shoot
an artillery piece why not just make a
tube
and put a rocket in it and makes them so
easy to fire and in such quantity
that they'll blanket the general
vicinity and that turned out to be a
brilliant doctrine as well but again it
reflects the idea of
quantity good enough versus a few
high quality caliber weapons
thank you for watching we hope you're
enjoying our highlight series and
invite you to explore our complete
course on the second world wars
all of hillsdale college's online
courses are free
and for everyone who loves to learn